while redheaded Russian spies grumpy
wizards and even talking raccoons have
become household names one of the first
Avengers has flown way under the radar
for far too long from her first
appearance in 1963 to her latest
incarnation the wasp has been setting
milestones for a character known for
shrinking she's grown more than just
about any costumed hero in Marvel's
Pantheon so here's the untold truth of
the wasp Avenger assembler it's taken
some time for the wasp to get her do in
the MCU but in the comics she was there
from the beginning
along with Thor Iron Man Hulk and
ant-man the wasp is one of the original
five members of the team that appeared
in Avengers number one and she even gave
the team its name after the Hulk asks
what the heroes should call their new
team the wasp suggests Avengers and
ant-man approves the name before she
even gets to finish the sentence with
one heroic pose the team has been
christened and the name has stuck for
the Earth's Mightiest Heroes ever since
Janet takes the chair along with being a
founding Avenger and the one to name her
home team the wasp is a landmark Avenger
in that she was the team's first female
chairperson keeping her job through a
healthy chunk of the 80s in Avengers
number two 1/7 the Watts called for
elections for a new chairperson
nominated herself and quickly won with
the support of Captain America Thor and
Iron Man she was a popular and effective
leader and remains one of the few Marvel
heroes who can give orders to Captain
America without making you wonder why
he'd follow them save for a brief leave
of absence when the vision took over the
team of the wasp remains chairperson for
five years until Avengers number 278
when she stepped down after a brutal
storyline that saw the Masters of evil
successfully invade Avengers mansion and
among other things beat their Butler
Edwin Jarvis so badly that he wound up
in the hospital and put Hercules in a
coma the wasp that almost was in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe the wasp isn't
the Janet Van Dyne that we know from the
comics instead that codename went to
hope Van Dyne played by Evangeline Lilly
she first appeared in 2015 ant-man and
finally got her own super-powered
shrinking costume in ant-man and the
wasp in a 2012 Q&A however Avengers
director Joss Whedon revealed that she
almost made her way to the big screen a
few years earlier worried that Scarlett
Johansson wouldn't return to the MCU as
Black Widow Whedon wrote what he called
a very waspy draft that featured the
tiny heroine in a tribute to the wasp
status as a founding Avenger obviously
Black Widow did stick around as a core
member of the team but finding out how
close we got does leave us wondering why
not have both the girl who was the wasp
Stieg Larsson's novels about anti-social
hacker Lisbeth Salander were published
posthumously but were popular enough
that author David lager Krantz was
tapped to continue the series in the
first of lager Krantz as additions to
the millennium series the girl in the
spider's web lager Kratz reveals that
was Janet Van Dyne who inspired Lisbeth
to give herself the hacker ID of wasp as
well as inspiring the wasp tattoo on the
back of Lisbeth's neck at first glance
it would be easy to assume that lager
Krantz is simply an old Marvel fan who
threw in his own childhood favorites
which checks out when you discover that
the book also included villains using
names like Thanos and Zemo but the
author insists this isn't the case
speaking with the verge in 2015 lager
Krantz claimed he hadn't read Marvel
Comics as a child and he was googling
the wasp while trying to figure out why
Larsson gave Lisbeth the codename
according to him his image search turned
up a character who looked exactly like
Lisbeth Salander if there's anything
that would make a marvel fan raise an
eyebrow at lager Krantz a story it's the
notion that he was able to find a
picture of the wasp that looked anything
like Lisbeth the only times Janet Van
Dyne looked even slightly goth were
alternate universes seven names aren't
enough 2009 Secret Invasion event
concluded with among other things the
apparent death of Janet Van Dyne four
years later it was revealed that she'd
actually been trapped in a microscopic
universe instead because in superhero
comics that's something that actually
makes a lot of sense
in the meantime Hank Pym Janet's
ex-husband and on-again off-again lover
paid tribute to Janet by taking up the
name of the wasp and led a new lineup of
Earth's Mightiest Heroes in the pages of
Mighty Avengers
what makes that notable is that it's
actually just one in a string of code
names Pym has given himself over the
years he's been known as ant-man giant
man Goliath gigantis yellowjacket dr.
Pym and even Ultron it's enough to make
you wonder if the guy was just waiting
for Janet to die so he could add one
more superhero name to his collection
the unstoppable wasp
the most recent air to take up the
mantle of the wasp is Nadia Van Dyne
daughter of Hank Pym and Hungarian
scientist Maria Travoy a-- the new wasp
first appeared in a 2016 free comic book
day issue and soon was a regular member
of the all-new all-different Avengers
Nadia is an interesting fusion of her
father her namesake and the Black Widow
raised in the same infamous Red Room
that made natasha romanoff the spy she
is Nadia escaped only when she was able
to get her hands on the Pym particles
that fueled her father's powers after a
reboot of Avengers Nadia enjoyed a shot
at her own ongoing title the only solo
Marvel wasps title ever for eight issues
she starred in the unstoppable wasp and
founded her own team the genius and
action research lab also known as the
agents of girl thanks for watching click
the looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]